plus de 15 millions d'euros c'est le
budget 2010 8 adopté lors du conseil
d'administration de l'établissement
public interdépartemental yvelines hauts
de seine avec une large majorité des
dépenses de fonctionnement des services
d'adoption d'entretien des routes et
d'archéologie des domaines mise en
commun entre les deux collectivités
c'est un budget qui est dans la
continuité du processus de fusion que
nous avons engagées c'est un processus
progressif mais aussi irréversible notre
objectif c'est effectivement de faire
fusionner nos deux départements de
manière à n'en former qu'un seul
l'adoption de ce budget montre la
détermination des élus à aller au bout
de la fusion un point de vue partagé par
nicolas dainville nommé président de la
commission développement économique et
tourisme à la place de son prédécesseur
jean michel fourgous montrer
l'importance des coopérations qui peut y
avoir entre nos départements yvelines et
hauts-de-seine sur ces enjeux là de
développement économique
c'est très important et de tourisme on a
des synergies à trouver et donc ça est
l'enjeu de la commission trouver des
synergies et des coopérations à
l'échelle de nos deux territoires
la fusion des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine reste la priorité de
pierre bédier de patrick devedjian
ils restent aussi mobilisées avec les
autres présidents de départements d'île
de france pour s'opposer au projet de
métropole du grand paris